salut à tous ces pêcheurs de trésors en
compagnie de tom & company et compagnie
voilà bonne compagnie en bonne compagnie
donc aujourd'hui pacha léman dans un
canal bien sympa bon on a déjà commencé
mais je vais pas vous spoiler c'est un
bon endroit un criminel et où c'est
parti pour la pêche
allez baptiste aux lancers waouh
ça du sahara star bon alors qu'est ce
que j'ai de beaux
essais lourd
franchement je sais pas
aux eaux un tour de table 1,2
c'est bien
non
owen rallonge électrique ça c'est une
première
oui
tu crois
c'est une bonne rallonge
au bond pour empêcher que l'accord
allait super longoria pas le tour et il
est où
ouais ouais c'est lui qui est démente et
je le rattrape et
abondant l'aja fait une autre pareil
plus loin mais
alors là j'ai quelque chose
oh
c'est étonnant
ouais y'a un sachet plastique en plus
alors
un anneau un anneau gastrique
et là j'ai un truc dans du don du web
dans un sachet
au nom
final pas grand chose d'intéressant
et il y avait une pièce je cours après
ça centime de 2011
non tu te calmes ma pauvre mère un ca
non non non elle est trop vieille
bon alors peut-être jouer est un petit
et j'ai quelque chose d'intéressant les
gars j'en suis sûr
l'âge de 109 le sang c'est la trouvaille
du jour
[Musique]
au coffre-fort
a maintenant des mots à chaque lot
derrière
la csu attend le bel attrapé pour pas
qu'ils vident
d'abord cela il était dans un mur
les
dix jours il est rempli rempli de base
il ya des choses dedans je crois
que nous laisser des indices
en général il est tout ce qui ce qui est
difficile à revendre ou l'épreuve donc
des 3100 combrouze ouais il est rempli
je sais pas de quoi mais il est rempli
mais attends pas sur le chemin ouais
alors
les détentions le chien vous allez être
pas en marron là
j'ai l'impression qu'il va juste être
jolie mais
s'il ya un truc m banier ouais tu
attends
ça va faire une gamme une gamelle pour
astor
faudra agrandir le trou je vais
bombail indoor se lie à rien on passera
à l'eau à la maison mais
ouais je suis contente et je les ai
sentis j'ai dit à la caméra là j'ai un
truc bien
alors tom ton premier coffre fort qu'est
ce que tu en penses bah écoute
un peu un peu vide mais non franchement
c'est sympa comme truc c'est toujours
émouvant
ouais tu vas sortie il te reste encore
du câble en plus concret me semble que
j'ai quelque chose
aux
os et une visseuse
après le tour et la visseuse
perceuse sans fil taddart au magret
batterie donc bonne dépollution
ouais y'a même la mèche ça c'est cool
yann en bout
ça serait utilisent et
que ça pourrait pas être un coffre
peut-être
tu vas voir tu vas être content
tu fais que me dire c'est quand qu'on en
fait hein c'est quand qu'on en fait un
mois je veux inviter les collègues tu
vas voir
tu vas voir alors attends c'est un peu
galère up et ben c'est un barbecue
ou peut être encore
là c'est plus une coïncidence là ça fait
beaucoup
non je suis dessus
yama
ouais c'est petit
m
le plus important c'est ça le nickel du
moteur yamaha et ben là encore il va
bien remplie encore ça peut être quoi ça
petit scout
alors que tom a fait une trouvaille
oh ouais t'as raison effectivement on
parlait dans un truc louche fois ci
encore quelque chose de s'en charger je
trouve
à quoi que non non non non non non ça
n'est pas à merde
si un bout
j'aime j'aime beaucoup mais je sais pas
si je n'en tire
encore un tour sûrs
je ne sais pas ce que c'est votre choix
ok
c'est quand même bizarre de jeter ça
la
à huy où là qu'est ce que c'est ça déjà
c'est pas un cadre mais assez notable
ouais c'est une table talons en acier je
pense à ouais bien joué alors de pêche
avec
un gros un gros ver de terre est sympa
tu as enfin eu celui qui décéda rokita
leur
site ah oui c'est un truc ouais c'est un
poteau ou un truc comme ça non
un panneau peut-être non
c'est la barre de fer
dans la vase mais ça c'est galère à
sortir en poche ou va pas passer la
voiture est habillée du cuivre
c'est déjà bien ouais cool bon curry des
abbés ça vient c'est pas si lourd
alors la coincer un peu
aux anneaux
aux
sympa ah il est beau hein j'aimerais
bien ma table basse et voilà la table
café baptiste voilà les deux objets qui
ont été pêchés aujourd'hui donc plutôt
sympa
c'était dans le coffre j'ai pas vu s
était encore battu vesa prix ça c'est le
pâté 1 il a ouvert le paquet il n'a pas
résisté
[Rires]
j'adore cette démarche
même rasta il sait pas trop ce qu'ils
voient ben écoute et on espère que vous
avez apprécié cette vidéo en tout cas
nous c'était un plaisir en compagnie de
tom donc les réseaux de tom sont
derrière description fin merci pour
l'inviter
je vous ai pas trop payer votre canal
mois ces boîtes de pâté pour ce soir un
peu de coca ça fait un bon souvenir
année je pense que c'est du pâté de la
région vous
inspire pas trouvé encore beau aller la
semaine prochaine pour une vidéo de
pécharmant
voit le coffre bien remplie belle
journée pêche tu es content harasta il
fait la gueule